Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Teleport to Mars and hop into your flying
car.
Maybe.
Our expectation that sci-fi technologies would
become reality -- like flying cars and Moon
colonies -- came from the pace of innovation
leading up to the Cold War Space Race.
If man can go from flying across the Atlantic
Ocean to landing on the Moon in only 50 years,
then surely by 2015 we’ll all have flying
cars.
Well, the problem with flying cars is basically
everything.
Current models are really roadable aircrafts,
because combining a great plane and a great
car creates something that’s neither.
Safety is also an issue.
Driving in two dimensions is already dangerous
with over 1.2 million fatalities worldwide
each year - and cars falling out of the sky
would make matters worse.
Realistically, flying cars have to be completely
automated.
What we really need is a scientific breakthrough
that solves taking off and landing from your
driveway without giant noisy propellers, or
that keeps us from having to drive carplanes
to the airport...
like somehow manipulating quantum gravity,
which at this point is still theoretical.
Teleportation is actually possible - it’s
just really hard.
Quantum teleportation allows us to transmit
the state of an atom or photon over long distances,
with the current record being a photon teleported
over 88 miles.
The process works something like this: You
have three photons with quantum states A,
B and C. B and C are entangled and remain
entangled whether they’re in the same room
or one is on Mars.
You basically measure the photons and use
that information to turn to C into A, and
effectively teleport the subatomic particle
state data of A -- not its actual physical
matter -- to Mars.
The problem with teleporting a human is the
amount of data we’re made up of.
A calculation by the University of Leicester
puts us at approximately 2.6 x 10^42 bits
- and transferring that on a bandwidth of
30GHz would take 350,000 times longer than
the universe has existed.
Also, to teleport this way, you would have
to die and be reconstructed, which raises
concerns about the human soul, spirit or consciousness
and whether that’s all just data that can
be measured and copied.
And you can’t teleport to a place humans
have never been before - you could only teleport
to a lab stocked with a pile of atoms waiting
to re-construct you.
Space colonies require a massive amount of
will and investment.
A recent study suggests that a minimum of
10,000 people are needed to provide the genetic
diversity a self-sufficient space colony requires.
A fleet of 25 ships holding 3 passengers each
with a roughly two year round-trip time would
take 266 years to transport 10,000 people
to Mars.
It would be much easier to start by setting
up a dome colony on the Moon, sections of
which get almost eternal light for solar power
and greenhouses.
Other parts of the Moon even have access to
large deposits of water ice - although it’s
so widely distributed, we’d need to develop
a way to harvest it.
While there, we’d learn everything from
paraterraforming, which is creating a pressurized
air-tight roof, to how lunar gravity affects
pregnancies.
We can take that knowledge to Mars, which
may hold the key to discovering extraterrestrial
microbial life.
This could show us a different model for biology.
Life on Earth all has roughly the same chemical
makeup, so comparing it to a new biological
system would greatly advance our understanding
of biotechnology and medicine.
So the universe could be filled with single
planet species that have gone extinct…but
we don’t have to be one of them.
And as always - thanks for watching!